has El mask accepted Islam he hasn't
accepted Islam but he's having doubts
about atheism he put out this tweet
which has gone
viral brothers and sisters just imagine
for a second that you give £10 in
donation and that £10 is used to buy
food or breaks or whatever to help the
people in Gaza but then just imagine
this amazing de that you want to do but
we turn it into a moneymaking machine
how the W is exactly that they take your
money and the money that we are going to
put in in this W this bill buing and
every single time the money generated
from that W that building is going to go
to our Palestinian brothers and sisters
for the next 20 30 40 50 60 100 150
years and this will be a form of
true I myself will be donating for that
inshallah click the link below and
donate may Allah subhana bless and
preserve you guys asalam alikum guys
hope you guys are well inshallah sub has
got some news for us has elk accepted
Islam he hasn't accepted Islam but he's
having doubts about atheism he put out
this tweet which has gone viral in which
he says atheism left an empty room
secular religion took its place but left
the people in despair childless Hedonism
Sans care maybe religion's not so bad to
keep you from being sad is it is that a
poem it's a poem but it's also so rich
because he's showing people what the
journey is you go into atheism it's
sadness it's Hedonism is childlessness
and what do you have at the end of it
nothing and it's supposed to Pro promise
you happiness and religion which is
supposed to be false belief in God which
is supposed to be destroying the world
is a source of happiness and everybody
knows that and this is you know
something that human beings cannot
Escape we were created our hearts were
created to worship God I mean it's very
interesting because for him to make it
rhyme you need to put effort into that
that's not just like I'm waking up I'm
just going to do a little tweet no no no
he actually fought that through and he
actually made sure that there's a rhythm
there's a rhyme it's like a poem cuz it
it shows me that he genuinely believes
what he's saying rather than it's just a
tweet because for him to like rhyme
those words but it's like someone who's
a Rapp or something like that it takes
time for him to compose that he he's put
effort into this not only effort he says
childless Hedonism Hedonism what does
that show he himself has lots of
children he know he can be as hedonistic
as he wants because he's got all these
things but he knows that's not what
happiness uh where happiness comes from
cuz essentially it has to come from
something spiritual so you know what we
should think about is if someone like
elong mus has everything in this world
they're not happy it shows you that the
worldview that they follow agnosticism
whatever it is is false so atheism no
matter how many things you have in this
life if you don't have Allah you have
nothing exactly and only only that he
has his um it's personal as well when it
comes to his son you know his his
son not daughter well well yeah
identifies as a girl I don't yeah
exactly so the point is this though it
just shows that he's realized the harms
of atheism and you know we're just you
know just made of liberalism and exactly
exactly you know there is no value to
life you can be whatever you like be a
chocolate be a dinosaur marry a piano
there was Oney who married the piano you
know so it just shows you that you don't
have a moral compass uh and that's why
he's seen it with his child he's seen it
with himself and Subhan Allah that's the
reason why you see a little a lot of um
far right atheist whoever they are for
that matter turning back to Christianity
we're seeing this rise now because they
don't see Islam as an option they don't
give it which shows their absolute
ignorance that they don't even read it
and because they don't see they see
Islam as foreign they are going into
Christianity and again that's the reason
why I think Allah in the Quran doesn't
even touch up doesn't really deal with
atheists as much and you know what's so
interesting about you're saying is
they're not even becoming Christian it's
purely a reaction to well woke
liberalism's wrong I'll just say I'm
this but they don't even understand what
that is on the other side and that's why
people like Jordan Peterson who you know
they Pander to the Christian audience
but they themselves is you know when
hijab asked him about God what do you
mean by God it's so vague so you know
people like Elon Musk he's very
influential person and he's somebody who
needs that guidance or else he is not
going to have principles and we've seen
this seen him flip-flop on things and
and you know change his positions and be
so fickle because when you worship God
when you are when you have a true Master
the the one true God being your master
then you don't need to worry about
Society you don't need that's true Free
Speech when you can say what you want
and you're not worried by what people
are going to say about you so that's
true freedom and this type of fake
religiosity which is woke liberalism is
not working I'll just go towards
whatever this is exactly and it shows
that their faith is faithlessness
because that's what it is because
they're going from atheism from
liberalism to Christianity and you Tommy
Robinson Jordan Peterson Elon Musk um
and a few other individuals Richard
Dawkins the cultural Christians meaning
they don't actually believe it it's just
basically we don't like woke uh the
liberal side of things and Christianity
uh not really but what's the what's the
less of the two evils or what's the one
that we can put out with oh we've got
Islam as a threat we'll never become a
Muslim because it's foreign and that's
that that toward us as a Muslim is being
a disbeliever you know that there is a
possibility Islam could be the truth but
you're not even going to explore the
idea and then you go to Christianity and
then you've got these individuals
talking about Christianity I mean Tommy
Robinson who goes to prostitutes smokes
Coke takes crap cocaine swindles his own
his own people exactly yeah Patriot yeah
okay he does this and then he uses the
the flag of Christianity you don't
believe anything about Christianity
because everything you criticize about
Islam is in Christianity yeah and what
we have to fundamentally remember about
a lot of this woke ideology which is
driving people towards religion now is
fundamentally it was a reaction it was a
reaction to a vacuum when you don't have
guidance what do you do you make up your
own stuff and then you get
contradictions this is why when you find
all these liberal uh woke woke people
sitting down in a room they disagree
with each other what do we include as
this what is the meaning of this what's
this what's that how should we treat
religion it's all a mess it's Darkness
upon Darkness upon Darkness but the
light is singular exactly that's what
Allah in the Quran you know when it says
would be created from nothing either
created of your but what do they say
surely they say we don't know and that's
what they on and there is no and if
there is no guidance there is
misguidance that's what it is insh and
that's what they're heading with their
misguidance and we ask Allah to open all
of their hearts um and yeah that was a
video brother sister from me and Sabor
if you guys would like to react to more
videos please send me videos on
Instagram that you want me and Sabor to
react to We will do it inah every thur
day brother and sisters till next time